[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN SCHROM: My name
is Benjamin Schrom.
I'm a product manager
on the Daydream team,
focused specifically on using
immersive technology like VR/AR
to make learning
and teaching better.
And I'm joined by two
members of our team here--
Jen, who's our program manager,
fresh from the Daydream keynote
just now, and Brandon, who
leads our engineering team.
So we're going to share some
updates on Expeditions with you
today, show what we've
been up to lately,
and then show you how
it's possible to make
your own learning
application with VR/AR,
and then offer some thoughts
about why you should do that.
Now, I'd wager if you ask most
people to list the things they
think VR would be good for,
most people would actually
put education sort of
at the top of that list.
We talk about it sort of
like it seems obvious,
and it is pretty obvious.
It's like the first thing we
did with it here at Google.
But it's not just
because VR is fun
or because it makes you feel
like you're somewhere else
that it's an obvious
fit for learning.
At least within our team,
it's because it powerfully
supports what our
values are as people
who are trying to enable better
learning with technology.
And what are those values?
Well, for us, we think that
good learning experiences
should be fundamentally
immersive, interactive,
and social.
And we act, no surprise,
that we actually
believe those same
things are the ones that
characterize VR experiences.
We think they
should be immersive
because being engaged,
interested, emotionally
invested-- these are really
important contexts in which
to learn.
And when things are immersive,
they are less abstract.
There's sort of less
cognitive load to process.
We also think that they
need to be interactive
because it's empowering
them agency as a user,
to not feel constrained, to
be able to have a thought
and see a result,
to be able to dig in
deeper when you see something
that piques your interest.
And they're social because
when people come together
as a group with
diverse viewpoints
that they discuss
and synthesize,
then we learn from one another.
And we end up with the sum
that's greater than the parts.
And this is important
to us at Google
because we aren't interested in
just creating future graduates.
We want to create
future creators,
inventors, problem
solvers, dreamers.
So that's why we
started Expeditions.
We wanted to give schools
a simple, approachable, and
immediately useful tool for
using VR in the classroom
and creating more of those
sorts of experiences on a more
regular basis.
And here to talk to you a
little bit more about it is Jen.
JENNIFER HOLLAND: Thanks, Ben.
So Expeditions was
announced two years ago,
and it was our first
large-scale effort
to bring VR in the classroom.
And all schools needed was a
simple smartphone or tablet
and a VR viewer,
and they could be
teleported all over the world--
underwater and even to Mars.
And on our team, many
of the same people
that built Classroom and
G Suite for Education
are the same people
that built Expeditions.
And we were able to rely really
heavily on those insights
that we acquired.
And one of the most important
things that we learned
is that you really need to
embrace the key functions
of a classroom.
That's students
engaging, interacting,
learning with each other
as well as their peers.
But there are also a
couple other things that
are actually really critical.
One is it needs to
be so easy to use.
You can't rely on teachers to
go to professional development
training to get
trained on your tool.
Two, you need to really
make that immersion,
that social connection
between teachers and students,
and students and students.
And make making sure that
it's engaging and interacting.
And you need to make sure
that your product works
on multiple devices
and platforms.
And that's really
important because schools
have a variety of
devices, and they
have a variety of platforms.
And they're not just
going to pick one.
And you can't expect teachers
to replace their materials
overnight.
And so you need to make sure
your tool or your product
can easily fit into the
existing curriculum.
And that's what we
did with Expeditions.
And just like
Chromebooks, we imagined
that the Expedition Kits
would be a shared resource
between classes and schools.
One of the biggest
things we realized
was that most teachers
weren't actually aware of VR
when we first started this.
And so what we decided to do
was bring Expeditions to schools
through the Expeditions
Pioneer Program.
And what we saw was that
once teachers got a chance
to see VR in action
and see how Expeditions
could transform their classroom,
they were immediately hooked.
And so the first year,
we took Expeditions
to over a million
students in 11 countries.
And we got incredible feedback,
particularly from teachers
in the UK.
So this past year we
actually went back to the UK,
and we just wrapped
up our program there.
And we took another
million students in the UK
on an Expedition.
And that's one in
about every eight
primary and secondary
students in all of the UK.
So that brings our
total number of students
that I've gone on and used
Expeditions to over two million
in the last two years.
And even after
Expeditions has been
used for weeks or
months or years,
we still get the
same teacher feedback
like this each and every day.
And so it's not just
the novelty of VR.
Clearly something is
working in the classroom.
And even more
importantly, we've heard
from thousands of students
from around the world who
have sent us personal letters.
And actually, these are just
the ones we got last week.
So you can see.
And I want to share one of them
with you because it's really
too precious not to share.
So this is from Lozen.
He's a student in the UK,
and he sent us this letter.
He said, "The whole
experience has
made me even more keen
to become a doctor
and study the human
body thoroughly.
The technology I used helped
me understand complex subjects
easily.
The solar system trip was
incredibly fascinating.
I did not feel myself
sitting in class.
Instead, I felt like Tim Peake
orbiting the solar system.
Now I'm not sure
whether I should
be a doctor or an astronaut.
I'm quite confused
at this moment.
My mom says I should watch more
of these Google Expeditions
before I make up my mind.
And for once, I think
I'll listen to her."
[APPLAUSE]
And yes, Lozen, we
agree with your mom.
You should probably go on
more Google Expeditions.
So things are clearly
working, and there's
quite a bit of momentum
that's actually
happening in the ecosystem.
We're seeing hundreds of
partners create Expeditions--
everything from traditional
education partners
like HMH to
nontraditional partners.
And we're working with museums
and cultural institutions
to create these Expeditions,
and we have a growing library
of over 600 tours.
We've also worked with
many hardware partners
to create certified
Expedition Kits.
So that all the hardware
that class of 30
would actually need
to take an Expedition.
And Best Buy Education was
one of our first partners
that we worked with last year
to launch an Expeditions Kit.
And we've now worked with
several other partners
around the globe to ensure
that schools actually
have certified kits to use.
We've also worked really
closely with teachers
to create supporting
lesson plans, which
is really important because,
as I mentioned earlier,
the lessons need
to be incorporated
into the actual curriculum
so that teachers
can use it seamlessly.
And so we partnered with
Tes to upload these lessons.
And Tes is a global platform.
It has over eight
million teachers
that are sharing and
learning with each other
and their lesson materials.
And what's really cool
is that we're also
seeing Expeditions used
outside of the classroom,
and that's something that we
didn't initially anticipate.
We're seeing government
organizations.
We're seeing nonprofits.
And we're seeing businesses
start to use Expeditions.
So let's just take a
look at one example.
And what you see on the screen
is actually our Coral Bleaching
Expedition.
So it's basically highlighting
the coral bleaching
event that took place in 2014.
And Michael, who is a
sixth grade earth science
teacher in New Jersey
used this Expedition
to explain the impact
that climate change was
happening to his students.
And they were able to go
underwater and actually see
the coral bleaching event.
And when talking to Michael
about the experience,
he highlighted that
Expedition continues
to add another layer
of authenticity
to the learning in the
classroom by using it
effectively and seamlessly
and integrating it
into the curriculum.
And what amazed me, though,
about this expedition
in particular was
that it was used
at COP21, which
happened in Paris
and it was the UN climate
change conference.
And I was actually
fortunate enough to attend.
And there was a
presentation with about 150
different scientists.
And it was a big panel.
and what was a one-way
dialogue between the panel
and the audience
became really lively
when a scientist actually
took an Expeditions Kit
and started passing it
out to the audience.
Everyone started going on
this expedition together
and actually could observe the
big coral bleaching event that
happened in Hawaii in 2014.
And the whole room was
transformed instantly.
So we're seeing some
of these examples
occur rather frequently.
And it's really exciting for
us to see not only Expeditions
is used in the
classroom, but how
it's used outside of the
classroom over the past two
years.
So what's next with Expeditions?
One of the most important things
that we value as an education
product team is listening
to teachers and students.
We take feedback
really seriously,
and we actually read every
single piece of feedback
that we receive.
And I kid you not, because my
team is the one that does it.
So we're actually working to
address some of the top feature
requests that we've gotten
from teachers and students,
and now we're going to take
a look at a sneak peek.
So with over 600
tours available,
we know it can be a bit
challenging for teachers
to actually find the Expeditions
that we're looking for.
So rolling out soon, you'll see
a new UI in the Expeditions app
that will allow you to see a
set of featured Expeditions.
You'll be able to search
by specific categories.
And we've also
improved the search.
So it'll make browsing a lot
easier to find the Expeditions
that you want.
And the other really
important thing
is that the UI is
really responsive.
And it works on a
tablet or a phone.
So we know if you're in Magic
Window mode or full screen mode
with a tablet, it
will work great.
Or if you're on your mobile
device, it will work fine.
And so now, I'm going
to turn it over to Ben.
BEN SCHROM: Thanks, Jen.
We've also heard from teachers
that they want more tools
to explain and highlight the
things within Expedition scenes
and environments.
So we'll be bringing this
new sort of Annotations tool
that lets you draw right
on top of Expeditions.
And we think this is going
be really, really useful.
If you think of
the number of times
when you're watching a sports
commentator use a telestrator
to illustrate a particularly
interesting play in a game,
it's exactly the
same thing here.
And the way this works is a guy
can draw something on the scene
with their finger or a
stylus, like here sort
of pointing out where a new
set of solar panels might go.
And then each of the
connected explorers,
they see that same thing
reflected on there's as well.
There you go.
It's really cool.
And now for the number
one most requested
feature of all-- the ability
to explore on your own.
Now we see firsthand each day
how powerful a teaching tool
Expeditions can be when used
in a classroom of 30 students.
But we also acknowledge
that as much learning
happens outside the classroom
as happens within it.
You don't always find yourself
with a willing and able teacher
right there in
the room with you.
So we'll soon be making
Expeditions available in a Solo
Mode that lets you experience
them without a live guide
present.
We've built out a full
VR UI within Expeditions
that lets you do everything
right there, like searching
and discovering awesome
Expeditions content all in VR.
And when you've found
the Expeditions you like,
you can dive right in and step
through the scenes and sites
within that Expedition
at your own pace.
You can learn more
by bringing up
this info panel with
relevant facts and details.
And just so you don't feel
like when you're alone with VR,
we've added support for
narrations to accompany you
as well.
NARRATOR: View of the
spot where Hamilton fell.
This 1830 view of
the dueling grounds
in Weehawken, New Jersey,
shows a memorial to Hamilton
with Manhattan in
the background.
After being shot
by Burr, Hamilton
was rowed back across the
river to Manhattan by friends.
According to a--
BEN SCHROM: So that should
give you a little taste.
But we've already
had some really,
really amazing folks
provide narrations.
And I'll again pass it back
to Jen to tell you about that.
JENNIFER HOLLAND: Does
anyone recognize the voice?
I heard Hamilton.
It was Lin-Manuel Miranda,
who is the American actor
and playwright.
He wrote Hamilton,
also starred in it.
And so some of the new
tours that will actually
be coming out as
part of Solo Mode
will be a couple
of Hamilton tours.
And it will be about Hamilton's
life and the place where
he dueled with Burr.
And just for the record,
these Expeditions
won't actually save you any
money on a Broadway ticket.
And we've also partnered
with Major League Baseball.
And so we've created five
new narrated tours with them.
And so you can step
up to home plate
at Camden Yards or Citi Fields.
You can learn more
about MLB Statcast,
and you can learn about the
career of a baseball beat
reporter.
And all of these new
Expeditions will also
be available to schools
through the live guided mode.
And we've also had
several teachers
who've already created
lessons to correspond
with these specific Expeditions,
which make it really
easy for them to incorporate.
And those are also on Tes.
So Solo Mode will
work on Cardboard,
and it will work
on Android and iOS.
And we're also really
excited that Expeditions
will be coming soon
to Daydream devices,
so that you can explore
Expeditions on your own
or with a live guide.
BEN SCHROM: We are doing demos
of Solo Mode in the Daydream
tent just right next door, so
go check it out in the Sandbox.
So VR is amazing at making
you feel like you're somewhere
else, like you've been
transported to a new place.
But we've also heard from
many students and teachers
that they want to interact
more with things or objects
that you might find
in those places.
It was actually one
of the first things
that struck us when
watching Expeditions VR used
in the classroom.
It was sort of the fact
that things in VR scenes
had a physical placement.
And that actually
changed the way
that students recalled
and talked about them.
Like a student that would see
an Expedition about a shark,
they'd actually point to
the place in the scene
where they saw that shark.
It became fixed in
their spatial memory,
not in this sort of
textbook on a desk.
And there may very well be
something else going on here.
There's this idea that's really
popular in cognitive science
circles right now called
embodied cognition.
And basically that
theory is that our bodies
play a much bigger
role in how we think,
learn, and remember than we've
generally thought in the past.
So the theory is that when we
move around and look around
and see things
presented in AR or VR,
that can tap into some
very powerful capabilities
of our bodies plus our minds.
So Tango is the technology that
allows us to do that with AR.
And we've combined the live,
social, teacher-curated
capabilities of
Google Expeditions
with the power of Tango
to augment the environment
with virtual objects
and animations.
Tango uses sophisticated
computer vision combined
with some simple
sensors and a smartphone
very much like the ones that
you all have in your pockets
right now to sense the depth and
dimensions of the environment
that you hold that phone up to.
So what does this sort
of mean in practice
in terms of how a
teacher would do it?
Well, it makes it
possible for a teacher
to sort of digitally
map their classroom
and place digital objects
in them as if they
existed in that space for real.
And because Tango creates that
canonical sort of digital map,
the objects placed in this space
are persistent across sessions,
can be shared with
other devices,
and allow for
students and teachers
to share a common view of that.
And that's one of
the key things that
makes Tango a unique and
really, really powerful thing
in the classroom.
AR isn't new in the classroom.
There's lots of actually really
awesome learning applications
that use device
cameras on a tablet
to do pass through in order
to show digital objects.
But those cameras see the world
as a flat, 2D environment,
and they can't create that sort
of shared social experience
where a classroom
can collectively
stand in front of an object
and talk about it like it
was right there in the room.
And we've also given
teachers similar controls
that they have to those
in Exhibitions VR,
allowing them to point
things out, change the object
and control the
pace of the class.
And it's been really fun
to sort of grant teachers
this new superpower
to magically go deeper
into any subject
in the classroom.
And instead of, or maybe
more importantly in addition
to the traditional
content used in schools,
AR can place inaccessible things
right in front of the student.
So we've seen it
encourage more curiosity,
engender more questions and
conversation among teachers
and students, and
we think it can
serve is a really, really
powerful complement
to VR experiences as well.
VR takes you like
anywhere in the world,
and AR brings anything
in the world to you.
So let's take a look at how AR
is being used in the classroom.
Let's just watch
this quick video.
Same one we showed at the
keynote, but we love it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- All right.
Who wants to see a volcano?
3, 2, 1.
- Wow.
- Look at that lava.
Look at that smoke
coming out of that.
- Pretend you're an airplane
and fly over the tornado.
- That's the top of it.
- What do you see?
- These are
asteroids, meteorites.
- We're learning about
DNA and genes, things
that we can't see.
And so the most exciting thing
for me with the AR technology
was that I could see kids get an
aha moment that I couldn't get
by just telling them about it.
- The minute I saw it
pop up on the screen,
it made me want to
get up and walk to it.
- You get to turn around and
look at things from all angles,
so it gives us a
nice perspective.
- See if you can
figure out what that
might be based on what you know
about the respiratory system.
- I got to see where the
alveoli branched off,
and I could look inside them
and see how everything worked,
which I never saw before.
And it was really, really cool.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
JENNIFER HOLLAND: So
that video is actually
from a couple of
our pilot schools
that have been using
AR in their classroom.
And we've been piloting
with a number of schools
all over the world.
The feedback has been
incredibly positive,
and we've learned a
great deal and really
seen some amazing, creative ways
that teachers have incorporated
AR into the classroom.
Similarly, how we saw
Expeditions VR incorporated
into the classroom.
And so here's just one example
from our pilot, which I just
love.
How many of you remember
taking a math field trip?
Oh we have one, two.
OK.
You took a math--
most of us don't get to go
on field trips in math class.
And yet, learning about
math in the context
of the actual real world
is really powerful.
And so that's what we actually
saw with a middle school class
in New York who
used Expeditions AR.
We worked with the teacher to
create this mini golf lesson
to calculate how golf balls
form different angles as they
hit the obstacle.
So throughout the room was
this amazing mini golf course
in the classroom.
And the students could see
the different holes and how
the different angles
changed when the ball hit
specific obstacles.
And just like we did
with Expeditions VR,
we'll be bringing
Expeditions AR to schools
this fall through
the Pioneer Program.
We want to give
teachers the ability
to see how this technology
can be interactive, engaging,
and fun with their students.
And so if any teachers
are interested,
they can sign up
right on our form,
and we'll be in touch with
more information soon.
And you can also check out the
demos in our Sandbox as well.
But if you're a developer
who's really excited about AR
and wants to work with
us to build AR lessons,
please express interest
on our partner page.
We've worked with so
many different partners
to build Expeditions
VR, and we want
to do the same with
Expeditions AR.
So definitely sign up.
And now I'd like
to turn things over
to Brandon, who's going to
talk to you about building
your own VR and AR experiences.
BRANDON WUEST: Thanks, Jen.
All right.
So as Ben and Jen have
really highlighted,
we have seen huge
success with Expeditions
as an educational product
through its use of VR
to enable immersive learning.
Additionally, our early efforts
to bring AR to the classroom
have shown a lot of promise.
However, isn't enough for us
to be building these AR and VR
products alone at Google.
We really need developers
to be focused on education
as well to help
grow the ecosystem.
But why do I want this
ecosystem to grow?
Well, I think it's the right
thing to do for the kids.
I mean, as a father myself
of three young children,
I want to see
education transform,
to become richer
and more engaging
for future generations.
I've already started to notice
that with my own children,
I notice that they learn better
if they can actually interact
with something, whether it's my
son building a leprechaun trap
or my daughter crafting
a tower with a 3D pen,
or my youngest child
chewing on a sock.
Maybe not so much the
sock, but hopefully you
see where I'm going.
But it's important to
note that AR and VR
educational experiences
aren't just relevant inside
of the classroom.
There's actually also
an enormous potential
for their use in professional
education as well.
So I think this
story is actually
a really good example of this,
and it's really interesting.
So what this story
is talking about,
it's talking about how a
utility company has started
using an immersive group
experience to give people
exposure to what it might be
like to work in a local sewer
system.
Though after reading
this, this is actually
one instance that I'm glad that
we have not cracked virtual
smells yet.
So what I want to do
now is to give you
a really quick overview of
some of the tools available
that can allow you to build
your own AR and VR experiences.
So first off, I want to talk
about Expeditions and its two
fundamental features.
First, Expeditions is immersive.
We use 360 imagery to surround
the students and the subject
matter.
Second, it provides a
co-located guided experience
that allows teachers
to control and augment
the experiences they
deem appropriate.
So first, let's talk
about the easiest way
to get 360 imagery into
your own application that
can be viewable in
Cardboard or Daydream
or even outside of a VR viewer.
First, you need to start with
something like the RICOH THETA
camera or Cardboard camera
that works on Android and iOS
to capture your imagery.
Once you have your
360 content available,
one of the easiest
ways to actually make
this viewable in
your application
is to use something
called VR view.
Now, VR view is a
drop-in component
for viewing 360
photos and video.
And let me walk you through
a quick sample on how
to do this on Android,
but be aware this is also
available on iOS
and the web as well.
So step one is to add the VR
view dependency to your gradle
build file if
you're using gradle.
Next step is to actually
add the VR panorama view
to your layout.
And then finally, you simply
take your VR panorama view
and you use that to load
and display your image.
And almost like magic, it's now
viewable in your application.
And it not only is viewable
in your application in VR,
you can also view
it in something
that we call Magic
Window mode that
allows you to view it
outside of a viewer
and move your phone around.
Now I realize that I'm going
over this very, very quickly,
but I'm just trying to give
everyone a quick overview
of all these tools.
So next up, how can you enable
a co-located guided experience?
It's actually really
straightforward
with the Nearby API.
Let me quickly walk you through
on how to do it on Android,
but this is available
on iOS as well.
First up for writing the Nearby
API is, just as with VR viewer,
is you add the dependency
to your gradle build file.
Then what you want
to do is you want
to create a message listener.
And now this message
listener is what
you use to actually receive
and process your messages.
So you create your
message listener--
create your message listener--
and then once you
have that listener,
then you subscribe that
against the Nearby API.
Pretty simple.
Now once you actually
have your application that
can listen to and receive
and process your messages,
then you can have your
application actually
publish these messages
out to clients.
Now, again, I went over
this pretty quickly,
but if you want to
learn more about VR
view or the Nearby API,
here a couple of resources
that you can check out.
360 photos are great.
They are simple and
easy to add to your app,
but they're frankly
pretty limiting
because they restrict you to
a certain type of content.
As you start to
prepare experiences,
say for our upcoming
standalone headset
that we announced in
the keynote yesterday,
you're going to want something
that's more flexible and more
powerful.
So what are your
options around building
more advanced experiences
without getting your hands
dirty with OpenGL or similar?
Enter WebVR.
Google has been a strong force
behind the WebVR standard,
and today it is fully supported
in Chrome for Android, Firefox,
Oculus, and Samsung browsers.
That's all great, but what about
building your own experiences
that use web technologies?
What I want to talk
about is A-Frame.
A-Frame is a web framework
for building virtual reality
experiences.
Now this actually
isn't a Google product,
but I want to talk about it
because it's one of the easiest
ways that I've personally found
to build VR experiences that
target the web.
So for instance, let's take
a look at the 360 photo
I showed you earlier
in the VR view example,
and let's say we wanted to add
a 2D image overlay on top of it.
This is actually something
that's pretty non-trivial
to do with VR view.
What you can see
here in the sample--
and this is actually a complete
sample on how to do this--
it's very easy to add
our 360 photo and then
our 2D image overlay and a
very concise amount of HTML.
And this should also look
very syntactically familiar
for those of you with web
development experience.
And then here is this example
running in Chrome for Android.
Amazing.
Now I'm going to try to
talk about a slightly more
complex example.
Now, when I was in
school, I struggled a lot
with the concept of
imaginary numbers.
I mean, for one, the name
is ridiculous, right?
They're imaginary numbers.
They're not even real.
But besides the fact
I think that the name
choice of imaginary
numbers is really poor,
I remember the concept
to be really intimidating
because it wasn't grounded
in anything tangible.
To help illustrate
what I mean, let's take
a look at this parabola,
x squared plus 1.
Now the fundamental
theorem of algebra
actually states
that there should
be a value for x that
causes this parabola
to cross the x-axis, but
we aren't seeing that here.
So what are we missing?
Well, the trick
here is that there
is a value for x that causes a
parabola to cross the x-axis,
but it requires us to
use imaginary numbers.
And one of the reasons
this example of applying
imaginary numbers
seems so inaccessible
is because educators
have largely
been limited to conveying
information like this on a 2D
plane, like a piece of paper.
But just as we represent
positive numbers
on the number line in one
direction and negative numbers
in the other direction,
we can actually
think of imaginary numbers
as just another dimension.
When we represent our
parabola in 3D space,
our applied use of
imaginary numbers
seems a lot more obvious.
You can clearly see that
our parabola intersects
with the x-axis, right?
It's obvious.
Well actually, it's
probably not obvious to you.
And if you're feeling
completely lost, great.
That's my point.
I'm trying to explain all
this using traditional 2D
presentation tools.
Now imagine if you could enable
students to explore concepts
like imaginary numbers in VR.
What's amazing here is
that someone has actually
already built a graphing
calculator application called
MathWorld VR using A-Frame.
Also, not only is this
tool available today,
but it's completely open source.
So if you want to take a look
at a more advanced example
of using A-Frame
or targeting WebVR,
this is a great place to start.
And if you want to learn more
about A-Frame or MathWorld VR,
you can check out these links.
So everything I've shown
you up to this point
has only enabled VR, and I
haven't talked about AR at all.
Google is pushing toward
a web AR standard.
But today, one of the
best tools for building
AR experiences such as
our Expeditions AR app
that you can see in
the Sandbox next door,
is with something called Unity.
Now if you've been building
3D games or VR content,
it's very likely
you've heard of Unity.
If you're new to this space,
there's a good chance maybe
you aren't familiar with Unity
or haven't heard of it at all.
And that's OK.
Unity has been historically very
popular for building mobile 3D
games, but the same features
that have empowered developers
to create amazing
games actually also
apply really well to AR and VR.
So this is why we build
Expeditions AR using Unity.
Because, one, it provides
really robust support
for importing and
manipulating 3D objects.
It provides a
multiplayer API that
works with peer-to-peer
connections, which
is conducive to our traditional
co-located student-teacher
classroom set up where an
internet connection may
be unavailable.
And most importantly, it
provides simple integration
with Tango.
And Tango is at the core
of Google's AR tracking
capabilities.
Now to provide slightly
more depth on this topic--
and if you've been
paying attention,
you might realize that's
a pun, though a bad one--
let's talk about the three
key features of Tango.
So first, Tango provides
our position in 3D space.
So we know where our
device is looking
and where it is located.
And this is what allows
students to walk around the room
and see objects from different
perspectives and distances.
It also provides
surface detection.
So we know a floor is a
floor and a desk is a desk.
And this is what allows
us to place objects
relative to our physical
space and allow teachers
to place objects on
tables just as they would
traditional classroom materials.
And then, finally,
Tango does all of this
by giving us a
global understanding
of our position in space.
So when we leave the
classroom and come back,
the objects remain.
Now if you want to
learn more about Unity
for Daydream or Cardboard
or Tango integration,
you can check out
these resources.
I realize I went
over this very fast,
but hopefully they
gave you somewhat
of a broad understanding
of some of the tools
available that will allow you
to build your own AR and VR
experiences.
All right.
Let me hand you back to Ben.
BEN SCHROM: Thanks, Brandon.
Why are we so excited
to have you guys build
AR and VR learning
experiences, and why do we
think it's like almost
an urgent thing?
So sort of perfectly
encapsulated in this quote
from one of my heroes,
Seymour Papert.
Does anybody know
Seymour Papert?
We should all try harder
to learn like children
is basically the point here.
Papert had such an
influence for us,
though, because he was
one of the first people
to see computers not as these
things that have generally
characterized people's
understanding--
these big information
stores that
are good at doing
repetitive tasks,
sort of like the logical
extension of an encyclopedia.
But he saw them as
these things that
could be harnessed by
people to create things,
to learn by doing,
by making new things
by being able to actively
try and fail and try again.
But here's the great irony.
In the last 30 or so
years since Papert
began to compel us to
rethink how to use technology
to support human learning,
what we've actually seen
is we've made much more progress
teaching computers how to learn
than we have with people.
So I'll give you
an example of this.
Do people remember Deep Blue?
Do people remember
Joel Benjamin?
Does anyone remember
Joel Benjamin was
the chess grandmaster
that the Deep Blue
team worked with at IBM
to actually encode Deep
Blue's game strategy.
They basically extracted
as many if/then statements
as they could from
Joel Benjamin's mind,
and they created this
powerful computer
that could do what Joel Benjamin
could do, just do it faster.
And it was an amazing
achievement for AI at the time.
But then last year, just
22 years later, there
was AlphaGo, the computer that
defeated one of the world's
great Go players.
But this wasn't done by coding
a computer with like everything
a human knows about
the game's strategy.
This was done by
programming a computer
to learn about how to
learn about what a good Go
strategy might be.
So instead of one really
smart Joel Benjamin,
you basically have this ignorant
crowd of really good learners
who just played Go all the time.
And to put that in some
context, the difference
between the number
of moves in chess
and the number of moves
in Go is the difference
between the number
of atoms in your body
and the number of
atoms in the universe.
And that in like 20 years.
So what happened that allowed
for such dramatic progress
in such a short time?
How is that milestone of
artificial intelligence that
was achieved just 20 years
ago sort of cute in comparison
to what we can do today?
Well, it turns out
that programming
a computer to be
smart is actually
much harder than programming
it to learn to be smart.
Put another way,
artificial intelligence
grew into machine learning.
So instead of jamming computers
full of if/then statements,
we give them the ability
and some structure
to observe success or
progress, let them try and fail
and try again.
We gave them the same gift
of learning that we're all
born with as children--
the same gift that leads
Brandon's youngest kid
to eat his sock.
So what do I take
away from this?
So much of traditional education
and its accompanying technology
tries to give kids
that old notion
of artificial intelligence.
Think about all of
the facts you were
asked to memorize, all the
standardized bubble tests
you took, all the times the
solution was presented to you
as choosing the right
if/then statement.
So if it took giving
computers the technology
to experientially learn at
scale to make them capable
of tackling these
cosmically-hard problems like
Go, then I think it should make
us realize that the technology
we need to be giving humans
to help them learn needs to be
focused on helping them
learn by experiencing--
by having agency, not just by
giving them a bunch of facts.
And that's exactly
why the emergence
of widely available and
powerful, immersive computing
like VR and AR is such
an exciting opportunity.
It can enable the right kind
of learning moments at scale,
provide people trying to learn
something with experiences,
with curiosity, with
wonder, with trial and error
that can be arrived
at quickly and safely.
And they can inspire kids.
And that's a much
more powerful force
than any educational technology
that we could actually create.
So if we-- and that
includes all of you--
if we get this right,
we have a chance
to give the same gift
that we spent the last 20
years giving to rack-mounted
servers to our own students.
So that's why we're really
excited to see what we all do.
So thanks very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]